Which actor who passed away in 2021 was a key
player on "Pee Wee's Playhouse"? And who inspired
a whole new generation of actors? Keep watching
for those and more acting greats we lost in 2021.
Actor John Paragon died in April 2021, at 66.
He was best known for playing Jambi the Genie
on "Pee-wee's Playhouse." Paragon met series
star Paul Reubens through the Groundlings,
the renowned improv troupe that
launched Will Ferrell, Kristin Wiig,
and Melissa McCarthy on the path to Hollywood
stardom. Reubens recalled on Instagram,
"[John] was sly and wickedly funny.
We became best friends instantly.
In a group of exceptionally talented
and funny people, he stuck out."
On top of playing the disembodied genie, Paragon
also provided the voice of Pterri the Pterodactyl
and was also a writer and director on several
"Playhouse" episodes. He appeared in a number
of other hit TV shows over the years — most
notably, "Seinfeld." His character Cedric,
was a thorn in the side of Kramer in three
memorable episodes including "The Soup Nazi."
Actor Frank Bonner, best known for playing
the spectacularly dressed Herb Tarlek
on the classic sitcom "WKRP in Cincinnati,"
died in June 2021, according to TMZ. He was
79. His daughter broke the news, posting
on the official "WKRP" Facebook page,
"He loved his fans and was still signing
autograph requests up until the last few
weeks of his illness. Thank you to all who
followed his career. He will be forever missed."
"I love you…I really do."
Bonner made his first onscreen appearance
in the 1967 horror film "The Equinox
...A Journey Into the Supernatural."
But he was best known for his TV work.
After early appearances in shows
like "Mannix" and "The F.B.I.,"
Bonner landed the career-defining role of Herb
Tarlek. He portrayed the character in all but
two episodes of the series. His co-star
Loni Anderson told the Associated Press,
"He was one of the funniest men I
had the pleasure of working with,
and he was the nicest man I have ever known."
Actor Joanne Linville played a Romulan
[RAHM-you-luhn] commander in "Star Trek:
The Original Series" and went on to appear in
the likes of "Gunsmoke," "Barnaby Jones" and
"Hawaii Five-O." She died in June 2021,
at 93. Her family shared in a statement,
"[She] lived a full life.
[She was] one whose spirit,
passion for art and life was an inspiration
to all who had the pleasure of knowing her."
Linville made her debut in the '50s with
movies like "The Goddess" and "Copper Canyon."
But she was perhaps best known for her memorable
guest role in "The Enterprise Incident," in which
her Romulan commander captures Captain Kirk and
Mr. Spock — falling in love with the latter.
"It will be our secret."
British actor Jackie Lane – best known
for playing the Doctor's companion,
Dodo Chaplet, in the long-running sci-fi series
"Doctor Who" — died in June 2021. She was 79.
After getting her start in local
theater as a teenager, by the 1960s,
Lane had secured regular theater work.
She moved to London to pursue a TV career
and landed a role on the BBC's
short-lived soap opera "Compact."
Having appeared in 19 episodes of "Doctor Who,"
she was then let go from the series. Disheartened,
Lane left the industry for years, but kept her
ear to the ground as an agent for voice actors.
Actor and renowned drama coach
Ann Ratray died in June 2021,
at 81. Her son, "Home Alone" star Devin Ratray,
confirmed the news on Instagram, writing,
"She was in her bed surrounded by
her family. […] The family requests
privacy […] and appreciates your sentiments."
Starting out in the industry as a Miss America
contestant in 1958, she starred on Broadway and
landed a few small TV and movie roles in the
'70s. But Ratray would become best known for
her mentoring in later years. She prepared her son
for his turn as Buzz McCallister in "Home Alone"
and was influential in the career of "Catch-22"
star Graham Patrick Martin, who tweeted,
"Ann Ratray is the reason I am
an actor. Forever grateful."
Bulgarian singer and actor Lorina Kamburova,
who featured in a number of horror movies,
died of pneumonia in May 2021. The
condition was caused by COVID-19,
according to the Russian outlet,
Gazeta. She was just 30 years old.
Her career began in her native country,
with the series "Liaisons" in 2015.
Two years later, she appeared in three horror
films, including a prequel to Tobe Hooper's
"The Texas Chain Saw Massacre"; 2017's
"Leatherface." The final product didn't
fare all that well with critics,
but the Los Angeles Times noted,
"[It's] the best 'Chainsaw' movie that doesn't
have 'directed by Tobe Hooper' in the credits."
Lorina landed a spot in 2017's "Nightworld," and
then "Day of the Dead: Bloodline." In what would
become one of her final roles, the actor played
Dr. Sandy Peterson in "Doom: Annihilation."
Soap star Stuart Damon, who played Dr.
Alan Quartermaine in over 300 episodes
of "General Hospital," died in June 2021. He
was 84 years old. His son recalled to KABC,
"['General Hospital'] was his favorite
place to be. He loved playing Alan
and was always so appreciative of that
role and that job. It was his passion."
Having gotten his start in theater, Damon
launched his TV career in the U.K. on shows like
"The Saint," "The New Avengers," and "The
Champions." He worked out of London for over
a decade, but trekked back to the States for
the iconic soap. He said in a 2010 interview,
"I was thinking 'General
Hospital' might be a 13-week gig
and 31 years later, I was still there."
His character was killed off in 2007, but he
continued to return in flashbacks. The soap
veteran went on to appear in "As the
World Turns" and "Days of Our Lives."
Model and actor Daniel Mickelson, died
at just 23 years old, on July 4th, 2021.
He was best known for his
role on Brat TV's "Mani."
"There's no time like the present."
His sister, model Meredith Mickelson,
revealed the news on Instagram, writing,
"My heart is shattered and to write this
feels so wrong. Yesterday, I lost my brother,
best friend, and the other half of my heart.
There wasn't a person I loved more on this Earth."
Mickelson made his acting debut in 2019, playing
con man Billy on the "Mani" web series. The
Atlanta-born up-and-comer landed his first film
role soon after, appearing in the indie horror
"The Killer Clown Meets the Candy Man." He also
reportedly was just beginning his modeling career.
Meredith's tribute post was quickly flooded
with heartfelt messages from other famous faces.
Jordyn Woods sent her prayers, while Paris Hilton
wrote of her sadness about the news. Among the
most heartbreaking tributes was the one made by
Daniel's girlfriend, Maddie Haley. She wrote,
"I wish my plans to spend the rest of my life
with you weren't stripped away from me like this."
Filmmaker, director and actor Robert
Downey Sr. — father of Robert Downey
Jr. — died of Parkinson's in July 2021. He was 85.
The New York native enlisted in the
Army when he was still in his teens
and would land in minor league baseball, before
writing his first play. After cutting his teeth
with Off-off-Broadway productions, he
made the low budget feature "Babo 73."
While his films were never box office draws,
the critically-acclaimed works would inspire
a generation of filmmakers.
One was Paul Thomas Anderson,
who went on to cast Downey Sr. in 1997's
"Boogie Nights." His best known film as a
director was 1969's "Putney Swope." It was added
to the U.S. National Film Registry, in 2016.
Veteran actor Suzzanne Douglas
died of cancer in July 2021,
at 64. She starred in the '90s sitcom "The Parent
'Hood" and later appeared in Ava DuVernay's
critically acclaimed drama "When They See Us."
DuVernay described her in a tweet, writing,
"[Suzzanne was] a quiet, elegant force. A
gentlewoman. A gem of a lady. A confident,
caring actor who breathed life into
the words and made them shimmer.
I'm grateful that our paths in this life crossed."
Douglas grew up in a "rough" part of
Chicago, and went on to study theater
at Illinois State University, alongside the
likes of John Malkovich and Gary Sinise.
Douglas made her on-screen debut in 1981 and would
become a sitcom mainstay the following decade.
In what was her best known role,
Douglas played matriarch Jerri Peterson
on "The Parent 'Hood" from 1995 to 1999.
Texas native Charles Robinson —
best known for playing court clerk
Mac on the sitcom "Night Court"
— died in July 2021. He was 75.
Robinson made his big screen debut in
Jack Nicholson's 1971 directorial debut,
"Drive, He Said." And by the early
'80s, he was landing recurring TV
roles in shows like "Buffalo Bill." But
in 1984, he took his career-defining
turn as Mac the popular clerk on "Night
Court." He once said in an interview,
"Most people really liked Mac because Mac
kinda kept a lid over the pot. I will live
with 'Night Court' for the rest of my life.
I could do films, theater, television
forever, and it's always 'Night Court.'"
One of his final projects was
Freeform's "Love in the Time of Corona,"
in which his wife co-starred as his nurse.
"Cheers to you, my dear."
According to the Hollywood Reporter, actor Robert
Sacchi died in June 2021. He was 89. Sacchi looked
so much like Humphrey Bogart that he once starred
in a film called "The Man With Bogart's Face."
"Didn't I see you sometime on
television in old movies?"
"No, that's somebody else."
"You sure look like you."
"No, I look like him."
While Sacchi made an appearance in a music
video for Phil Collins' song "I Wish It
Would Rain Down," he was primarily known for
comedy. The 1999 rom-com "Blast from the Past"
became his final role. But fans
of action flicks will no doubt
recognize Sacchi as a control
tower engineer in "Die Hard 2."
Martial arts movie icon "Sonny" Chiba died in
August 2021 of complications from Covid. He
was 82. He made his international debut
in the 1970s with "The Street Fighter"
and later appeared in "Kill Bill" and
"The Fast and the Furious: Tokyo Drift."
A black belt in numerous disciplines, Chiba
was the real deal when it came to martial
arts. His first crossover success
was 1974's "The Street Fighter,"
the dub of which became a cult favorite in the
U.S. The film would inspire Quentin Tarantino,
who referenced it in his script for 1993's
"True Romance." Chiba passed away before his
final feature film — the gangster movie,
"Bond of Justice: Kizuna" — was released.
TV legend Ed Asner , best known for playing
news producer Lou Grant on both "The Mary Tyler
Moore Show" and the series "Lou Grant," died in
August 2021, at 91. His family shared in a tweet,
"We are sorry to say that our beloved
patriarch passed away this morning peacefully.
Words cannot express the sadness we feel. With a
kiss on your head — Goodnight, dad. We love you."
"You've got spunk."
"Well, yes…"
"I hate spunk!"
After starring on Broadway, and in film and TV,
Asner hit the big time when he was cast as
cranky Lou Grant on "The Mary Tyler Moore Show,"
a role that would provide him the chance to
flex his dramatic muscles in the spinoff,
"Lou Grant." Across both shows, the role
would net Asner five of his seven Emmys.
Of course, younger audiences probably
know Asner best as Santa Claus from "Elf,"
and as the voice of Carl Fredricksen in "Up."
Asner was inducted into the Academy of
Television Arts & Sciences Hall of Fame in 1996.
Emmy-nominated actor Michael K. Williams
was found dead in his New York apartment
on September 6, 2021. He was 54. Best
known for his spellbinding turns on
numerous HBO shows and movies, a rep
for the network said in a statement,
"[He was] a member of the HBO
family for more than 20 years.
While the world is aware of his
immense talents as an artist,
we knew Michael as a dear friend who was beloved
by all who had the privilege to work with him."
"On a personal level, I truly believe
that all my characters, they choose me."
Williams worked as a background dancer for
Madonna, Crystal Waters, and George Michael
before switching his focus to acting. He was
soon spotted by none other than Tupac Shakur,
who pushed for him to be cast in the 1996 film
"Bullet." Williams would go on to play a number
of gangster roles in the years that followed.
But his portrayal of openly gay stick-up man
Omar Little in "The Wire" garnered widespread
praise. The actor told the New York Times,
"Omar definitely helped soften the
blow of homophobia in my community,
and it opened up a dialogue."
His most recent work was as Montrose
Freeman in "Lovecraft Country,"
which earned the versatile star his
fifth and, ultimately, final Emmy nod.
Comedian and actor Norm Macdonald died of cancer
in September 2021. He was 61. The TV icon starred
in films including "Dirty Work" and "Screwed"
but was best known for his time on "Saturday
Night Live." Macdonald kept his diagnosis secret
for nine years. As a friend of his told Deadline,
"[He didn't want it to] affect the way the
audience or any of his loved ones saw him.
Norm was a pure comic. He once wrote that
'a joke should catch someone by surprise,
it should never pander.' He
certainly never pandered."
A 1990 appearance on "Star Search" led to TV
writing gigs, and McDonald soon found himself
penning gags for "Roseanne." But in 1993, NBC
came calling, and MacDonald began a five-year
stint on "SNL" that's remembered chiefly
for his time fronting "Weekend Update."
His turn as anchor was defined by his relentless
criticism of O.J. Simpson and his murder trial,
which some say contributed to his
axing from the show. Apparently,
MacDonald himself believed that his humor was just
too out there. As he once told The New York Times,
"We were doing experimental stuff."
Macdonald went on to star on "The Norm
Show" and worked on several movies with
former "SNL" cast members; most notably
Adam Sandler's "Billy Madison," Eddie
Murphy's "Dr. Dolittle" — as Lucky the
dog — and Rob Schneider's "The Animal."
"And that's the way it is,
folks. Goodnight and good luck."
Actor James Michael Tyler was known all
around the world for his portrayal of Gunther,
the eccentric and shy manager
of Central Perk on "Friends."
He died of prostate cancer in October
2021, at 59. His rep shared in a statement,
"The world knew him as Gunther (the seventh
'Friend')…but Michael's loved ones knew him
as an actor, musician, cancer-awareness advocate,
and loving husband. If you met him
once you made a friend for life."
His character's crush on Jennifer Aniston's
Rachel Greene became a running gag over the
course of 10 seasons. And it
was a remarkable storyline,
when you consider that Gunther wasn't even
supposed to be a fully-realized character.
Tyler was originally cast as a background
actor, but "Friends" co-creators Marta Kauffman
and David Crane saw something
more. They said in a statement,
"His unique spirit caught our eye and
we knew we had to make him a character.
He made Gunther's unrequited
love incredibly relatable."
He went on to appear in several other hit
series, but he'll always be remembered as
part of the "Friends" family. Jennifer Aniston
took to Instagram to write in Tyler's memory,
"'Friends' would not have been the
same without you. Thank you for the
laughter you brought to the show and to
all of our lives. You will be so missed."
Comedian and actor Anthony "AJ" Johnson died
in September 2021, at 55. He was best known for
his standout turn as Ezal in the classic comedy
"Friday." As his rep told The Hollywood Reporter,
"We lost an icon. He has left with us amazing
memories of his laughter, dynamic acting skills,
but most of all his enormous
personality and heart of gold."
Co-writer and co-star of the
stoner comedy, Ice Cube, tweeted,
"[He was a] naturally funny dude who was
straight outta Compton at the same time.
Sorry I couldn't bring your character Ezal
back to the big screen in 'Last Friday.'"
According to Johnson, he was supposed to reprise
the role in 2000's "Next Friday," but Cube cut him
out from the movie to save money. He told Vlad
TV that he and Cube "shook hands" on a figure,
only for Cube to hire someone else and begin
shooting early — without telling Johnson.
"If you made it out of Compton,
you can make it anywhere."
Character actor Dean Stockwell
died in November 2021. He was 85.
Stockwell appeared alongside the likes of Errol
Flynn, Frank Sinatra and Gene Kelly as a child.
And after falling out of love with acting,
he experienced a career revival in the '80s,
appearing in "Paris, Texas," as well as
the David Lynch films "Dune" and "Blue
Velvet." He also played a crime boss in
Jonathan Demme's "Married to the Mob,"
which led to an Oscar nom
for Best Supporting Actor.
He became beloved by sci-fi fans for
his turn as cigar-munching ladies' man
Al Calavicci on "Quantum Leap,"
from 1989 to 1993. Scott Bakula,
who starred on the show, paid tribute
to Stockwell in a statement, recalling,
"Having been a famous child actor, he had
a soft spot for every young actor who came
on our set. I loved him dearly and was honored
to know him. He made me a better human being."
"I'm outta here."
Stockwell went on to land roles
on "Stargate SG-1," "Star Trek:
Enterprise," and "Battlestar Galactica."
Character actor Art LaFleur was best known
for his turn as baseball legend Babe Ruth
in the 1993 film "The Sandlot." He died in
November 2021, at age 78, of Parkinson's.
His wife, Shelley, confirmed on Facebook,
"He was a generous and selfless man,
which carried over to his acting,
but more importantly, it was who
he was for his family and friends."
LaFleur originally moved to California
in 1975 to become a screenwriter.
He went on to land roles in 1989's
"Field of Dreams" and 1992's "Mr.
Baseball," but fans never forgot "The
Sandlot." LaFleur once told Media Mikes,
"When I went into the audition
I went in 'as' Babe. […] I went in with
a cigar…the Babe always had a cigar."
Actor Joey Morgan died in November 2021.
He was just 28. Best known for his turn
as Augie Foster in the zombie comedy
"Scouts Guide to the Zombie Apocalypse,"
his rep confirmed to The Hollywood Reporter,
"It was a shock and devastated all of us
who loved him. He will be dearly missed."
"Scouts Guide to the Zombie Apocalypse" was
Morgan's acting debut. He went on to feature
in a number of other teen comedies, playing a
hacker in "Compadres " and later appearing in
"Sierra Burgess Is a Loser" and "Camp Manna." He
returned to the big screen in 2020, co-starring
in the critically acclaimed sci-fi adventure
film "Max Reload and the Nether Blasters."
Actor Heath Freeman was best known for
playing serial killer Howard Epps on "Bones,"
as well as turns on "NCIS" and "Raising the Bar."
He died in 2021 at the age of
41. His reps said in a statement,
"[We are] truly devastated at the loss. [He was a]
brilliant human being with an
intense and soulful spirit."
Freeman made his small screen
debut in a 2001 episode of "ER."
And in 2003, he landed on "NCIS." But
by 2005, he made his first appearance
as Howard Epps on Season 1 of "Bones."
Freeman appeared in three features in 2021,
including the Luke Wilson-led
football flick, "12 Mighty Orphans."
New York-born actor Yaphet Kotto,
who appeared opposite Roger Moore
as a corrupt Caribbean politician in
the James Bond film Live and Let Die
and later played engineer Dennis Parker in
Ridley Scott's 1979 sci-fi flick, Alien – died
in the Philippines in March 2021. His wife
confirmed the news in a Facebook post writing,
"You played a villain on some of your
movies but for me you're a real hero.
A good man, a good father, a good
husband and a decent human being."
He was 81.
Kotto made his movie debut
aged 23 in Nothing but a Man,
a film about a Black couple dealing with
racial discrimination in 1960s Alabama. His
sheer size led to him being cast in a variety
of hardman roles in the years that followed,
something that always bothered him.
He once told The Baltimore Sun,
"I want to try to play a much
more sensitive man. There is
an aspect of Black people's lives
that is not running or jumping."
Other notable credits include the
Stephen King adaptation The Running Man,
in which Kotto fought for his freedom
alongside Arnold Schwarzenegger,
and the '90s police procedural
series Homicide: Life on the Street.
Award-winning actress Jessica Walter, who
won an Emmy for her turn as a San Francisco
cop in Ironside spinoff Amy Prentiss, and
became known to later generations for playing
Lucille Bluth in Arrested Development
and voicing Malory Archer in Archer,
died in her sleep in March 2021. Daughter
Brooke Bowman said in a statement,
"A working actor for over six decades, her
greatest pleasure was bringing joy to others
through her storytelling both on screen and off.
While her legacy will live on through her body of
work, she will also be remembered by many for
her wit, class, and overall joie de vivre."
She was 80 years old.
The New York-born Walter began her career on
Broadway and quickly started turning heads,
picking up the Clarence Derwent Award for Most
Promising Newcomer for her work in the show
Photo Finish. She continued to impress
after making the move to the big screen,
where Walter played Clint Eastwood's
knife-wielding ex-girlfriend in the actor's
directorial debut, 1971's Play Misty for Me,
earning a Golden Globe nomination in the process.
She was up for multiple Emmys over the course of
her career, including for Arrested Development.
"I don't have the milk of
mother's kindness in me anymore."
"Yeah, that udder's been dry for a
while though, hasn't it? Kind of."
British character actor Paul Ritter, who won
praise for his powerful performance in HBO's
Golden Globe-winning miniseries Chernobyl, died
of a brain tumor in April 2021 at the age of 54.
Ritter was well known in theater communities
on both sides of the Atlantic, having been
nominated for both an Olivier Award and
a Tony Award in his time. He made his
on-screen bow in 1992, with an appearance in
the long-running police procedural The Bill.
He went on to carve out a career as a prolific
TV actor. Alongside his appearance in Chernobyl,
his best-known performance came in the
British sitcom Friday Night Dinner,
where he played oddball dad Martin Goodman.
Robert Popper, creator of Fright Night Dinner,
said that he was "devastated at this
terribly sad news" in a tribute tweet.
"Paul was a lovely, wonderful human being. Kind,
funny, super caring and the
greatest actor I ever worked with."
Grammy-nominated rapper and actor DMX, whose
songs regularly broke the Billboard Hot 100
in the late '90s and early '00s, died after being
hospitalized in April 2021. He was rushed to a
critical care unit following a drug overdose,
but ultimately passed away at the age of 50.
Born Earl Simmons in Mount Vernon, New York, DMX
spent much of his childhood in the care system
after being removed from his physically abusive
mother. He began developing his gritty stage
persona, "Dark Man X," during his time, and he
remained true to his name as his peers started
to gravitate towards designer labels and smoother
beats. Songs like "What's My Name" and "Party Up
(Up in Here)" had made him a star come the turn of
the millennium, and Hollywood soon came calling.
DMX appeared in a string of
action movies around this time.
For example, there was 2000's Romeo Must
Die, a martial arts-heavy Shakespeare
transplant starring Jet Li and Aaliyah. And
then, DMX headlined in 2001's Exit Wounds,
and 2003's Cradle 2 the Grave, alongside
Steven Seagal and Jet Li, respectively.
He never walked away from acting, and he was still
active in the industry at the time of his death.
British actress Helen McCrory, best known for
her turns as Narcissa Malfoy in the Harry Potter
movies and Aunt Polly in all five series of
Peaky Blinders, died in April 2021. She was 52.
McCrory was born in London but moved to Cameroon
and then Tanzania with her diplomat dad when she
was still just a toddler. She returned to the
UK for her studies, and after a year in Italy,
she enrolled at Drama Centre London. She made her
TV debut in 1993 and appeared in her first movie,
the Kate Beckinsale-led thriller
Uncovered, the following year.
She went on to appear in films like The Count
of Monte Cristo, Helen Mirren's The Queen,
and the James Bond installment Skyfall, but
she never lost touch with her theater roots.
Olympia Dukakis – the star of the stage
and screen who won an Oscar for her turn
as Cher's meddling mother in hit '80s
rom-com "Moonstruck" — died in May 2021,
her brother confirmed in a
Facebook post. She was 89.
The daughter of Greek immigrants, Dukakis was born
in Massachusetts and attended Boston University,
where she mastered in performing arts. She met
actor-producer Louis Zorich after moving to
New York, and they would tie the knot in 1962,
the year she made her debut. By the mid-1960s,
she had two Obie Awards to her name and was well
on her way to becoming a respected Broadway star,
though she'll likely be remembered
by most for her work on the screen.
Dukakis was named Best Supporting Actress at both
the Academy Awards and the Golden Globes for her
performance as Rose Castorini in "Moonstruck."
Sally Field, who worked with Dukakis on "Steel
Magnolias," called her, quote, "unique and
talented and one of a kind" in her own tribute.
Beloved Hollywood veteran Norman Lloyd, who was
one of the oldest living actors in the business,
died in May 2021 at the age 106.
The New Jersey-born, Brooklyn-raised Lloyd got
his first break back in 1932 when he was a student
at New York University. He would eventually end
up working with Orson Welles, playing Cinna the
Poet in Welles' famous adaptation of "Julius
Caesar." His first film — Alfred Hitchcock's
"Saboteur" — soon followed. The hit spy thriller
was the beginning of a long-lasting professional
relationship between Hitchcock and Lloyd, who
went on to produce and/or direct over 250 episodes
of "Alfred Hitchcock Presents" and "The
Alfred Hitchcock Hour" in the '50s and '60s.
Lloyd was nominated for a Primetime Emmy for his
work on the TV movie "Steambath" in the '70s,
and in the following decade, he became known
for NBC medical drama "St. Elsewhere," appearing
as Dr. Daniel Auschlander between 1982 and 1988.
Other notable roles include Peter Weir's "Dead
Poets Society," Martin Scorsese's "The Age of
Innocence," and Charlie Chaplin's "Limelight."
Comedian and actor Paul Mooney – who
regularly collaborated with Richard
Pryor in the 1970s and '80s and later
became known for his work on "In Living
Color" and "Chappelle's Show" — died of
a heart attack in May 2021. He was 79.
Mooney met Pryor at a party in the late
1960s, and the pair quickly hit it off.
They ended up penning an episode
of "Sanford and Son" together
and would collaborate many more
times in the years that followed,
including on the variety series "The Richard Pryor
Show," the stand-up film "Richard Pryor: Live on
the Sunset Strip," and on Pryor's biographical
vehicle "Jo Jo Dancer, Your Life Is Calling."
Mooney brought his patented style of comedy
to Keenen Ivory Wayans' "In Living Color"
in the '90s. And in the following decade, he
became a writer on another hit sketch show,
"Chappelle's Show." Mooney also appeared on-screen
in "Chappelle's Show," playing characters such as
a very opinionated movie critic and a
Nostradamus parody. Notable big-screen
credits include "The Buddy Holly Story," in
which he played seminal singer Sam Cooke,
Spike Lee's "Bamboozled," and the Mike Epps-led
comedy "Meet the Blacks," Mooney's final film.
Former child actor Kevin Clark, who played
percussionist turned drummer Freddy Jones in
the Jack Black film "School of Rock," died
after being hit by a motorist in May 2021.
Clark was riding his bicycle in his home city
of Chicago when he was struck by a car. He was
pronounced dead at Illinois Masonic Medical
Center around 45 minutes later. He was 32.
Clark landed his part in Richard
Linklater's "School of Rock,"
his one and only acting credit, after he
tagged along with a friend to the auditions.
His mother, Allison Clark,
told the Chicago Sun-Times,
"He just kind of shined. He took it on right
away, but he never really acted afterward."
He did, however, keep the music up. Clark went on
to play in a number of bands in the Chicago area
and even taught some classes. Robbie Goldberg, who
played with Clark in the band Robbie Gold, said,
"He was motivated and loved to write songs,"
His Hollywood career was short, but Clark was
a stand-out performer in "School of Rock,"
a cult favorite that spawned a Broadway show and
a TV adaptation. He was photographed alongside
co-star Jack Black as recently as 2018,
and Black said in an Instagram tribute,
"Kevin is gone. Way too soon. Beautiful
soul. So many great memories. Heartbroken."
Two-time Tony Award nominee Samuel E. Wright,
most famous for his iconic portrayal of Sebastian
the crab in Disney's "The Little Mermaid,"
died of prostate cancer in May
2021, Deadline confirmed. He was 74.
The South Carolina-native began his career on
Broadway, appearing in the original production
of "Jesus Christ Superstar" in 1971. He made
his TV debut in 1976 and went on to land a part
in 1988's "Bird," the Forest Whitaker-led
biopic about jazz musician Charlie Parker.
He voiced King Triton's forthright advisor
Sebastian in Disney's animated classic "The
Little Mermaid" the following year, a role
he would reprise many times in TV spinoffs
and related Disney media. He
once told Entertainment Weekly,
"Sebastian has given me what I've always wanted
as an actor, and that's immortality. As far as I'm
concerned, that's why I'm in the business. I want
the whole world to love me, remember me forever."
Wright got the chance to portray
another iconic Disney character
when "The Lion King" came to Broadway in 1997,
playing the role of Simba's father, Mufasa.
Veteran TV actor Robert Hogan died of
complications from pneumonia in May
2021. He was 87.
The New York-born actor served with the U.S. Army
in Korea and briefly trained as an engineer upon
returning, but an aptitude test told him that he
was in the wrong field. Hogan secured a place at
the American Academy of Dramatic Arts and went
on to become a stalwart on the small screen.
For many, Hogan was best known for
his recurring roles on classic ABC
shows "The Young Marrieds," "Peyton Place," and
"Petticoat Affair," though younger viewers will
no doubt remember him from his turn in HBO's
"The Wire." Hogan portrayed Louis Sobotka,
father and moral compass to Pablo Schreiber's Nick
Sobotka, in four 2002 episodes of the hit show.
Renowned character actor Ned Beatty, who
played ill-fated city boy Bobby Trippe
in John Boorman's 1972 classic "Deliverance,"
died of natural causes in June 2021. He was 83.
A native of Kentucky, Beatty made
his acting debut in his late teens,
scoring a singing part in a local stage
production. He went on to feature in the
original production of "The Great White Hope,"
which moved to Broadway and ran until 1970.
Two years later, Beatty made his memorable
and haunting movie debut in "Deliverance."
He would remain best known for Boorman's film,
but Beatty's most celebrated performance actually
came a few years after it — he was nominated for
Best Supporting Actor for his work in "Network."
"You have meddled with the primal forces
of nature, Mr. Beale, and I won't have it!"
Beatty would go on to work with many
more of Hollywood's biggest directors,
including Richard Donner, Steven Spielberg,
John Cassavetes, and Robert Altman.
Ohio native Lisa Banes, who was in
'80s films "Cocktail" and "Young Girls"
and later appeared in "Gone Girl" and "A Cure
for Wellness," died after a hit-and-run in June
2021. Banes was taken to Mount Sinai Morningside
Hospital, but she died 10 days later. She was 65.
Banes' career in acting began in the
city where her life was tragically taken.
She studied at New York's Juilliard School and
appeared in numerous Broadway shows. She made her
movie debut in Tony Richardson's "The Hotel New
Hampshire" in 1984, and by the end of the decade,
she was sharing the screen with Tom Cruise,
playing wealthy barfly Bonnie in "Cocktail."
She worked largely in TV during the 1990s,
co-starring in the Emmy-nominated drama series
"The Trials of Rosie O'Neill" before a string
of guest roles in the likes of "L.A. Law," "Star
Trek: Deep Space Nine," and "Frasier." Banes
would continue to appear regularly on American
TV screens, with casting directors often keen
to take advantage of her age-defying looks.
Philadelphia-born actress Marion
Ramsey, best known for playing
soft spoken Officer Laverne Hooks in the
Police Academy movies, died in January 2021,
her agency told The Hollywood Reporter.
The statement read,
"Marion carried with her a
kindness and permeating light
that instantly filled a room upon her
arrival. The dimming of her light is
already felt by those who knew her well.
We will miss her and always love her."
No cause of death was released. She was 73.
Ramsey made her first appearance as Officer Hooks
in 1984's Police Academy after spending more than
a decade in the theatre world. She remained a
mainstay of the wacky comedy franchise over the
coming years, working on six installments.
Rapper and actor Dearon Thompson,
better known by stage his Deezer D, died of a
suspected heart attack in January 2021. Thompson,
who appeared as affable nurse Malik McGrath in
all 15 seasons of the beloved medical drama ER,
was discovered in an unresponsive state at his
Los Angeles home, his brother told TMZ. He was 55.
Thompson made his first feature film appearance
in 1991's Cool as Ice, the critically panned movie
debut of Vanilla Ice. He made his ER debut in 1994
beginning a near-200 episode run on the NBC hit.
Thompson had been dealing with heart
issues for over a decade. In 2009,
he told RadarOnline that he was awaiting surgery
after, quote, "over 10 episodes of heart failure
in the last eight months alone." Doctors
identified a problem with his aorta. The Los
Angeles native was still making music and actively
promoting his songs at the time of his death.
British actress Barbara Shelley, who
appeared in numerous Hammer Horror films
during the 1950s and '60s, died in January 2021.
The veteran scream queen contracted COVID-19
after a routine hospital visit, her agent,
Thomas Bowington, told the BBC. She was 88.
Shelley trained in theater as a child but her
good looks naturally led her into the world of
modeling. Her dream was to act, however, so
when she was approached with an offer while
vacationing in Rome, she took a chance. Shelley
went on to appear in a string of Italian movies
over a four-year period, but it would be the
work she did after returning to the UK that
she would be best remembered for. The Londoner
became the go-to female star for Hammer Horror,
appearing in eight of the
studio's classic pictures.
"Let me kiss you."
Beloved soap star John Reilly,
best known for his 11-year run on ABC's
General Hospital, died in January 2021.
The actor's death was confirmed by one of
his daughters in a tribute Instagram post.
She wrote,
"Imagine the best person in the world.
Now imagine that person being your dad.
I'm so grateful he was mine. I'm
so grateful I got to love him.
I'm so grateful I made it in time
to hold him and say goodbye."
He was 86.
Reilly made his onscreen debut in the Midwest-set
soap opera As the World Turns in the mid-'70s
and would go on to become a regular
face on American daytime television.
He scored recurring roles on shows like
The Bionic Woman and How the West Was Won.
Tanya Roberts was best known for playing
geologist Stacey Sutton opposite a much
older Roger Moore in 1985's A View to a Kill,
the 14th installment in the British James Bond
franchise. The actress died from a urinary tract
infection that, quote, "got into her blood"
and developed into sepsis, her longtime partner,
Lance O'Brien, told Fox News. She was 65.
The New York native started out as
a model but made the transition to
acting a decade before her James Bond appearance,
landing a part in the horror flick Forced
Entry. Her first major role came in 1980,
when she joined the cast of the then-struggling
Charlie's Angels. She remained busy during the
1990s, when she made her first appearance
on That '70s Show; playing Midge Pinciotti.
Croatian-American actress Mira Furlan, best
known for her stints on Babylon 5 and Lost,
died in January 2021. Her death was
announced on her official Twitter account.
The cause of death was not revealed. She was 56.
Born in Zagreb, Furlan and her husband
emigrated to America in the early '90s
amid rising tensions in their home
country, settling in New York City.
Three years after the move, she landed what would
become her most iconic role: Minbari Ambassador
Delenn in Babylon 5. She briefly returned to
Croatia before jetting off to Hawaii to play the
part of Danielle Rousseau in Lost. She appeared as
the French loner in 20 episodes of ABC's hit show.
"You offered to fix my music box after all I've
done to you, striking you, shocking you."
New York-born actor Gregory Sierra, who
appeared in '70s sitcoms Sanford and Son
and Barney Miller, died of cancer in January 2021.
His widow, Helen Tabor, told CNN,
"He was doing the best he could
and just couldn't do it anymore.
He was quite wonderful, and my heart
is broken into 400 million pieces."
He was 83.
According to Deadline, Sierra began his career
as a member of the National Shakespeare Company,
appearing in a number of off-Broadway productions
during the 1960s. He made his screen debut in a
1969 episode of the Robert Wagner spy series, It
Takes a Thief. He would go on to become a mainstay
of the American TV in the years that followed,
popping up in numerous sitcoms and cop shows.
Award winning actress Cloris Leachman,
best known for playing Phyllis Lindstrom
on The Mary Tyler Moore Show and
“I am Frau Blücher “
…died of natural causes in January
2021. She was, quote, "one of the
most fearless actresses of our time," her rep
and friend, Juliet Green, told Variety, adding,
"You never knew what Cloris
was going to say or do,
and that unpredictable quality was
part of her unparalleled magic."
She was 94.
A native of Iowa, Leachman moved to
neighboring Illinois to study theater
at Northwestern University. She dropped
out before she could graduate and took an
unconventional route to Hollywood that included
an appearance at the 1946 Miss America pageant.
Her acting career began when she landed in
New York and got in with the Actors Studio,
but she wouldn't come to national attention
until she debuted on The Mary Tyler Moore
Show some 20 years later. She won two
of her eight primetime Emmy Awards for
playing the catty Phyllis Lindstrom, who
would later get her own spin-off, Phyllis.
"I'm afraid I've just been
too much of a real woman."
Hollywood trailblazer Cicely Tyson,
who paved a path for Black actresses during
a career that spanned more than six decades,
died in January 2021, her manager
confirmed to Variety. She was 96.
The East Harlem native worked as a model
before breaking into acting, appearing in
top publications like Vogue. She learned her craft
at the Actors Studio and became a regular face on
the New York theater scene, but she'll no doubt be
best remembered for the work she did — and didn't
do — on the screen. Tyson made her debut in short
drama Carib Gold and moved into feature films
proper when she appeared as a jazz club worker in
the Harry Belafonte picture Odds Against Tomorrow.
She largely avoided movies in the decade that
followed, making a conscious effort to turn
down roles that demeaned Black women. She returned
to the big screen with a bang in 1972's Sounder,
earning a Best Actress nomination for her turn
as Depression era sharecropper Rebecca Morgan.
"You got you a low life job, Mr. Sheriff."
Tyson was awarded an honorary Oscar
in 2019, by which point she was widely
recognized as one of the industry's pioneers.
Actor Dustin Diamond, who played iconic '90s geek
Samuel "Screech" Powers on the sitcom Saved
by the Bell, died of cancer in February 2021,
just three weeks after it was revealed that he'd
been diagnosed with stage 4 small cell carcinoma.
In a statement published
in Variety, his agent said,
"In that time, it managed to spread
rapidly throughout his system;
the only mercy it exhibited was its sharp
and swift execution. Dustin did not suffer."
He was 44.
A naturally funny child, Diamond landed the role
of Screech with next to no on-screen experience.
He debuted as the loveable loser in 1988
on the Disney Channel's Good Morning,
Miss Bliss, which would be picked up and
revamped into Saved by the Bell by NBC
when it was canned after a single season.
Saved by the Bell finished in 1992,
but Diamond reprised the role of Screech on
several occasions in the years that followed,
most notably in Saved by the Bell: The
College Years and Saved by the Bell:
The New Class. The California native appeared in
130 episodes of The New Class from 1994 to 2000.
Award winning star of stage
and screen Hal Holbrook,
best known for his portrayal of Mark Twain in
his enduring one-man show Mark Twain Tonight!,
died at his California home in February 2021,
his agent told The New York Times. He was 95.
His first on-stage performances took place when he
was stationed in Newfoundland with the U.S. Army;
he joined a theater group and appeared in a number
of local productions. He began working on what
would eventually become Mark Twain Tonight! in
1952, and four years later he shot to prominence
after Ed Sullivan invited him onto his variety
show. Remarkably, Holbrook would go on to perform
as Twain over 2,000 times, including two stints on
Broadway. The first run scored him a Tony Award,
and he was nominated for an Emmy when
Mark Twain Tonight! transferred to TV.
Star of the stage and screen Christopher Plummer,
known for a prolific career that
included playing Captain von Trapp
in the iconic Best Picture winner The Sound
of Music, died in February 2021. He was 91.
The Toronto native made his Broadway bow in 1954's
The Starcross Story and debuted on the big screen
four years later, starring alongside Henry Fonda
and Susan Strasberg in Stage Struck. The actor
disliked many of the films he appeared in during
the 1960s, including the one he would come to be
best known for — He famously called Robert
Wise's musical, quote, "The Sound of Mucus".
In the 1970s, Plummer bagged a Tony Award
for his work on the musical Cyrano and then
a Primetime Emmy for The Moneychangers, NBC's
adaptation of Arthur Hailey's political thriller.
He was nominated in the same category
for 2017's All the Money in the World,
a feat made all the more remarkable by
the fact that he stepped in to replace
Kevin Spacey in the role of J. Paul Getty just six
weeks before the film was due to be released.
Actress and singer Trisha Noble, who
played the mother of Natalie Portman's
Padmé Amidala in the Star Wars universe, died
in January 2021. The Australian died, quote,
"after an 18-month battle with mesothelioma,
a tumour caused by inhaled asbestos fibers,"
the Daily Mail reported. She was 76.
Born Patsy Ann Noble in Marrickville, Sydney,
she got her start on the Aussie variety show
Bandstand, which featured regular performances
from the likes of the Bee Gees and Grease star
Olivia Newton-John. Noble saw success in
Australia, but her career wouldn't take off
internationally until she moved to Britain, where
she secured a record deal with Columbia Records.
She later relocated again, taking the stage
name Trisha upon her arrival in the States.
She's perhaps best known for playing
Jobal Naberrie in 2005's Star Wars:
Episode III – Revenge of the Sith.
Actor and lifelong Buddhist Christopher
Pennock, who appeared in 126 episodes
of the Gothic soap opera Dark Shadows, and later
recurred on General Hospital, died in February
2021. He had been given a melanoma diagnosis the
previous year, Deadline confirmed. He was 76.
Pennock studied at the American Academy of
Dramatic Arts in New York and would go on
to finetune his craft with The Actors Studio
before making his debut on Broadway. He began
with understudy work, but he quickly leveled
up and started landing roles in productions
like 1969's Patriot for Me, which is
where Dan Curtis first laid eyes on him.
The Dark Shadows creator cast Pennock as
Leviathan, the first of many characters he
would portray — he's perhaps best known for the
twin roles of Cyrus Longworth and John Yaeger, the
in-universe versions of Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde.